China y el resto del mundo ya están tan
conectados como antes de la pandemia las
embajadas chinas a partir de hoy vuelven
a tramitar todo tipo de visados
incluidos los de turista también han
recuperado la validez aquellos visados
que fueron expedidos antes del 28 de
marzo de 2020 fecha en la que china
ordenó un cerrojazo para protegerse del
coronavirus las restricciones a los
visados eran el último vestigio de la
política cero covid que fue dinamitada a
finales de diciembre durante años viajar
a China fue una tortura conseguir un
visado solo por causas muy tasadas era
el primero de los problemas seguían los
carísimos y escasos vuelos las
innumerables pruebas médicas y las
larguísimas cuarentenas que tenía que
pagar el propio viajero China eximió de
las cuarentenas hace un par de meses y
solo exigía una prueba pcr que tenía que
ser realizada en un hospital o clínica
dos días antes de volar a partir de hoy
solo exige un test de antígenos cuesta
unos dos euros se pueden realizar en y
el resultado es inmediato esta medida ha
sido anunciada Poco después de que China
proclamara la victoria contra el
coronavirus y se espera que devuelva el
flujo de turistas extranjeros estos
pasaron de contabilizar 100 millones de
viajes en 2019 el último año
prepandémico apenas 5 el pasado año la
Industria Del turismo en China sin
embargo ha sufrido mucho menos que la de
otros destinos tradicionales como España
o Tailandia gracias a un mercado interno
de 1.400 millones de habitantes